bad in this drop truth you can't drop
true i'm not going to drop truth i'm
here to talk about fun stuff yeah fun
stuff
i'm here to do patty cakes we should we
should know that sam tripoli if he wants
he does have truth but you have truth
i will not be dropping any truth bombs
sam facts
hey wait if you talk about krav maga do
they do like host like fights like they
would for the ufc absolutely not sir no
because then you would be killing
somebody oh you shouldn't kill someone
yeah like yeah situation no there's not
a couple of people you'll find youtube
videos will be like
dude in russia they do crazy [ __ ] like
they're like meet me in a field and
we'll just [ __ ] fight but like boss
rooney had that krav maga thing was yeah
the bar he's like bam yeah i'll just
start fighting people
grabbing bottles smashing hats that's
what my boy this is so wait my boy boss
and amir perez
who is uh like the krav maga guy he's
like israeli special forces and all that
yeah yeah and he teaches all you have
jewish friends we get it
no amir amir was boss rootin's
main sparring partner yeah so they they
paired up yeah and both of them and i
met amir on warrior yeah um and they
paired up the both these guys paired up
and and they have literally a
self-defense
program oh yeah you can like
the boss rooting system yeah you said it
for years yeah no this is kind of new
it's like about a year old maybe oh
really yeah wait you're saying he has
his own style of yeah he and he had i
mean like pat miltage was like here's my
fighting right yeah here he get into a
cornfield and [ __ ] people up right well
these guys said here's what you do at a
bar here's what you do somebody attacks
you i love that [ __ ] and amir is the guy
on fight science where they had a live
gun yeah and like a live then they put
it to his back and the guy was he was he
pulls the trigger and he he disarms it
in real time he's that guy so when they
did fight science
john brenkus can you take your braces
out
is it bugging you no just yeah it's
bugging me and you're [ __ ] cause
you're 50. let him have it you are who
you are bro listen to this so nobody
goes oh man that 50 year old if those
teeth were just a little scary
never it would always talk about this
dude it's over dude i know it's like a
fork in it you are who you are i'm doing
it i'm doing it for a while this is
because your children helps you breathe
better right because i have issues with
my [ __ ] vanity yeah no my the roof of
my mouth is [ __ ] it's a pain in the ass
it's getting worse and it just causes it
causes one tooth to crack i i don't i
don't i don't care but anyway
as you say do you mind do you mind
thanks
so they they go to him he goes he goes
to the special forces community he goes
i need a guy i can put through like i
need to freeze him i need to put him in
really hot temperatures and he's got to
do this obstacle course but i need
somebody who can deal with all this
craziness every single motor every
you want that guy in here and if you
meet him he's super thick just one of
those guys and and he's the guy so he
has his own if you like krav maga i love
it he's it's my favorite thing like the
headquarters
like in [ __ ] yeah there's a couple of
them there's one yeah all black oh
that's what this word yeah and then
because of this stupid-ass virus
this stupid-ass virus thing sam sam no
you can say that i can say it right yeah
you can say that it got shut down yeah
it got shut down and two years of the
game the gangster gyms figured a way
around yes all the gyms i know like they
would have like it looked close but yeah
yeah they board they board that [ __ ] up
a little bit yeah
a long way like i just rewatched warrior
and by the way that was 14 years ago
and god do i look young god damn if i
age you look at yourself and you're like
frank grillo with like he was a young
man 14 years ago yeah any picture in
here you know what i mean that was four
14 years ago
oh my god you were kelly wasn't four
yeah
yeah but i mean christian was what six
yeah i know right
14 years ago you were tiger's age 14
years ago i'm terrible at math wow nine
dogs
i can't believe i'm the one that did the
math
i flunked first grade and i super
completed that you got the big brain on
sale yeah all right
you came through with that dog said nine
it's so crazy though it's weird
to see yourself camera
it's crazy so every time my daughter's
like on their so their birthday i have
this picture of me holding them
so every day on their birthday i take
the same picture and it's like in crazy
how much they're growing oh damn don't
tell them what uh yeah brian look at you
look oh my god [ __ ]
i mean
brian you don't look good stay honest
like you never clean shade well get
another angle and you'll see but brian
i'm sure i mean at that age you're like
i'm gonna lose all my hair soon and look
at you still have it yeah let's look at
the positives i'm still cute wait what
about that picture of you and brynn is
that the premiere of it that no that was
it that was the spike
so this award show that will never
happen again it's called spike guys only
awards yeah it will never happen again
spike was like oh we can't do was that
the last time it happened oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know then the stuff oh
it's just spike was could have been so
great right and then it was like the
ultimate fighter on there i have my i
had a show on my one show in history i
had on there dude i was doing stunts my
career started there with the ultimate
fighter
spike was the [ __ ] yeah and but then
they'd like i know where they're like
we're just gonna do stupid stuff like
you know can we do a half an hour of
fart sounds for the whole show but then
they did have cops for a long time too
spike was lit for a while it was great
and then they just they just banked on
the wrong i thought they had that live
pd
was it that no that went on fox oh yeah
right but you know cops is back of
course
well not on regular it's on fox on
demand or some [ __ ] you guys subscribe
everything's streaming now everything's
straight yeah well now now that whole
defund the police is such a liability
political liability for the democrats
they're all like hey don't mention i
love to see them backtracked like
we weren't saying like defund we were we
were saying allocate other resources not
everything fun yeah don't say defund
dude
bad choice what happened wasn't
something that happened to ame the mayor
and uh or someone in uh san fran yeah oh
yeah they were they they're she was like
this is a [ __ ] oh she said we just
kept getting people right there
london breed
london breed and she said the [ __ ]
stops now she said that at a press
conference and so
that's her because her car got jacked
she said she was at a party and 95
percent of the people at this party with
the elite in san francisco had all been
robbed and had an experience with crime
and then in new york the new governor
there he was like you know there's uh
eric adams there's a kid that was shot
and he was like dude i'm [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] telling you this stops now we're
doubling down on cops because he was a
cop yeah
cops this [ __ ] has got to stop
everyone's like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa yeah law and order what the
thing about beverly hills that the the
uh that woman who was murdered in
beverly hills have you heard of any
crime in beverly hills since i've never
heard dude
complete crime
she's a famous philanthropist and they
followed her home
and and they they robbed her and killed
her and and he was very famous too
because he just got wrecked into their
rockets
you were talking about that murder that
was in beverly hills yeah but but then
also
he had security there too he had
security there he was sleeping she got
murdered i only followed her home
because at three a.m it was planned and
yeah because he had security there so
they had a plan yeah
but have you heard it like i remember
they were like right like i made a joke
me and jay were driving down beverly
hills and his rolex i went you guys some
balls were in the rolex beverly hills
man well that's the whole thing but now
but have you heard anything like
one once once you start [ __ ] with the
rich rich yeah then you scare them as
soon as that happened boom so so la
county or the la
of
this council voted to defund the cops by
a hundred and fifty million dollars and
as soon as all that stuff started
happening like they were going to
nordstrom's and all that stuff gavin
newsom's like here's 300 million dollars
yeah so it was until they started
robbing rich people and all those giant
corporations that they started to like
change well nothing's going to vote you
out of office faster when people don't
feel safe especially the economy could
be [ __ ]
if people are scared to leave their
homes you're so [ __ ] you're so [ __ ]
you're so funny and when corporations
start going like walgreens and nordstrom
says hey hey san francisco we'll just
move our stores yeah
we'll just pack up and move our stores
because we can't do business here how's
that sound and all of a sudden they go
wait a minute and everybody else goes
yeah i'm going to go to texas we'll see
you dude yeah because you said they were
just walking straight up in walmart it
was under a thousand just [ __ ] they
were dropped prop 47 yeah anything any
any
any shoplifting under a thousand dollars
but the way i voted for that because the
way no the gross brian no because the
world the way they caught it
marxist
who's your dad castro come on bro
i can explain man
but the way they worded it on the ballot
was it was endorsed by by the chief of
police and stuff so i was like oh i
don't want people getting put in jail
like for a long time for like minor
crimes it doesn't make sense kids for
what marijuana oh
no you can't look it up on you well it's
repeated offenders yeah just keep
learning yeah and then like in new york
this young lady was uh the guy
stabbed her 90 times and he said six
offenses i thought that was here
90 times he stabbed her 90 times this is
two days ago in new york fallen 90 times
and then you look at the track record
and that eric adam's like what are we
[ __ ] doing dude it's like yeah you
guys want to play grab ass and let these
bad people back on the streets
and and also but also you you like you
just like don't make a rule for the
exception
okay but when you're talking about crime
there's some really really bad guys out
there so if it's weed i get that let's
not keep on yeah of course but if
they're multiple time offenders you
can't keep like drugs are one but
there's always if you're committing
crimes to get the drugs
domestic violence and you just keep them
back on the streets but the main thing
too is this in new york they did this in
the 90s and it really worked under
giuliani there was a i can't remember
who was who was a criminal psychologist
who said hold on guys he said
quality of life crimes so if you are a
guy who pisses on a sidewalk
uh and then you and then you graffiti
and you break a window
that is the kind of person including
people that jump turnstiles
that's the kind of person
that does a lot of other [ __ ] so that
behavior is just a little doorway so
when you see somebody [ __ ] around
like that typically what they found
that's what was that no no it's not but
not i'm saying it's tough to put that
person away for pissing no no that's not
what i know he was you
when you enforce the little crimes what
what you're doing you're stuck you're
catching them yeah and when you catch
those people they almost they have like
an outstanding warrant for sure they
have they've done 15 other things so so
you find that that behavior is a good
marker for a bigger [ __ ]
which is great but yeah but now they're
doing like you're talking about real
criminals letting them out and have fun
my father-in-law caught for three years
and he's like dude like by the time we
arrest him he goes i'm talking bad dudes
by the time we arrest him by the time
we're done fill out the paperwork
they're already out on bail
he's like so process of all this dude
he's like we didn't even most time we
just let him go because it's a waste of
our [ __ ] time wow he's like the rules
have to change just think of the process
of all this dude like coronavirus right
so it's coming out
it's totally real very effective make
sure you go get vaccinated um
so know what sam just said right dude
let's be careful with the komatar we
don't want to get platform okay but my
point is like gavin newsom right starts
doing this thing where he's releasing
people
out there because of covid right and
then what happens all of a sudden these
riots are happening and everyone's like
why are these right all these people are
let out then you got these da's who
aren't doing any kind of um any kind of
prosecuting like all this stuff is like
it's all been both it's all been like
step by step by step to destabilize
everything and people are waking up that
it's one side that's been doing all this
and it wasn't until they until these
people went to their neighborhoods
who's ultimately responsible okay here
we go hey i'm just by the way newsome
went to a jesuit high school thank you
the jesuits dude b let's take a little
break because sam is dropping some facts
and i don't like it but i'll tell you
what you should like what's happening
you should like some athletic greens
dude athletic and i like greens because
i know greens are very good for you
you're damn right they're good for you
and today's
podcast is brought to you by ag1 by
athletic greens listen man i'm talking
about superfood product it's basically a
multivitamin one scoop of ag1 contains
75 vitamins minerals whole food source
ingredients including a multivitamin
like i just told you multi-mineral
probiotic green superfood blend it's
delicious apparently you absorb all
these when you have like whole food
source ingredients you absorb it better
from what i understand yes it's
fantastic it tastes good join the
movement of the athletes podcasters
comics moms dads first timers rookies
whoever it is you need this in your life
to make it easy athletic greens are
going to give you an immune supporting
free one-year supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs for the first
purchase if you visit athleticgreens.com
fighter today again
simply visit athleticgreens.com
fighter to take control of your health
and give 81 a try
let me explain something to you right
now when it comes to grub hub yeah if
you're sitting there and you're like i
don't want to get my car and drive in
traffic you can pretty much have
whatever you need brought to your door
whether it's your favorite food whether
it's paper towels whether it's lipstick
you name it they'll do it all right in
30 minutes or less
dude yeah
dude and listen you need a paper towel
one coke whatever it is man from extras
to essentials grubhub now delivers all
of your go-to convenience items all day
long and all nice late night snacks it
doesn't matter convenience items that
are delivered right to your door
just in the nick of time and stay in
your undies you never have to train your
undies order your convenience items from
grubhub goods on the app or online
grubhub goods
i want to be optimized i want to be
optimized dude i want supplements i want
nutrition i want fitness i want apparel
i want that stuff where do i go oh i
know on it there's only one place if you
listen to any podcast we've ever done on
it's always been a part of it because we
trust them you guys trust them if you're
a new listener you should know we only
rock with one brand one brand only when
it comes to supplements and it's on it
on it.com slash fighter 10 off alpha
brain the shroom
tech man okay if you're like feeling
sick take that that stuff for real works
yeah it works shroom tech works um i
don't care that stuff is unbelievable
they got streamtech greens now which is
crazy wow krill oil joint oil total
human we got you covered vitamin d3
protein for you got coffee for you we
got fitness we got streaming fitness if
you're not ready to go to the gym yet
cool we got streaming on demand fitness
on in 30 home fitness programs steel
mesa club maces kettle bells the primo
bells battle ropes we got it all go to
onited.com for 10 off the best
supplements and workout gear ever on
planet earth thank you the jesuits dude
we're going to do this dude you you know
you don't even know that world that's a
different world yeah that's deep [ __ ]
you know what's crazy sam and this is
it's just mind-blowing to me that people
still put up with this
so newsom's at the super bowl right him
and garcia get caught without a mask at
the nfc championship game he gets lit up
on social media he goes i was holding my
breath all right you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
did he say that
yeah by the way i know the guy that took
that picture yep so
kevin so he so he goes i was holding my
breath forever yeah so
the people go i i don't know why peter
go okay we'll keep wearing our mask
they're at now
well two weeks later he's at the super
bowl again both pictured and seen
without a mask and every celebrity
without a mess
okay people are like all right i'll keep
wearing my mask and then
and then the the la rams parade is today
downtown yeah newsome goes it's outside
because every this can't be a super
spreader event everybody needs to be in
a mask outside
it i can't stand that guy
i can't stand them do you think that's
done to purposely get us to not know if
we're coming or going
like to really mentally break us down
but i i i just i just can't imagine
someone being like i'm going to parade
he said wear a mask i just like that i
can't believe that anybody's going to
yet i bet if we turn on the parade right
now nobody has a minute it's becoming a
political liability man for for these
guys wait till elections but how do they
well how do they not understand that
they're [ __ ] they don't you know how
do they understand they go back they're
too [ __ ] well because i think they're
all compromised that's why they like
this is done purposely like don't you
guys find it crazy that on like local
state
levels like there's term limits but
these people in washington could
literally be there like a thousand years
literally and nobody says anything no
matter what right it's like do you know
like four families have ran california
for over a hundred years yeah like
they're all related like newsomes
related to pelosi
and then there's uh the browns the
browns have been governor of california
and oregon then they're all related to
the uh political dynasties yeah and they
all just work together to keep stuff on
lockdown
it's crazy dude but like even if we're
like wait till elections bro it's gonna
be so awesome we'll get the other side
in dude it's like we just keep running
back and forth from r's and d's i do
joke about it's like running from like
elm street to camp crystal lake dude
you're just like going back
you know like anarchy is very
interesting like you're me more and more
i'm for anarchy and like meaning you are
i'm i don't know i like the idea sounds
really great to me like sell me on
anarchy right now well the whole notion
that like we govern ourselves
right and then like like that like
like somalia like okay that works out
that's not
right
the chazz district in seattle remember
they tried that yeah yeah yeah yeah they
already tried that it didn't work out no
but but hold on but that wasn't anarchy
no it was just letting kids play yeah
okay
that was playground [ __ ] and then
they realized there's some bad guys get
involved that and they're like hey my
friend got stabbed cops like sorry you
said you didn't understand the the the
the the king riot stopped when koreans
got on the [ __ ] they came forward
that so so everyone has fun until the
adults show up and the adults show up
after a certain time same thing with uh
wisconsin right like all that was fun
and games and then people oh you're
gonna loot everything we're gonna show
up with guns and that's when they shut
everything down yeah so okay i like that
that's what we're going to it's like
what is that
what is that fine line it's just
basically
most of your problems bro stem from
government right correct but the thing
the problem is sam is you're obviously
balls deep in it but most people are
getting their political opinions
whatever from the mainstream media for
sure and so legacy media has you're
never interested in they're they're
called they all have agendas i know but
they're also like talking to big tech
they're all correct they're all in lock
steps yeah so they'll all step by step
it could be education of the individuals
or the masses and you got to get them
away from cnn yeah but how would you get
people away from that the different
models
well the ratings are very low and a lot
more people are streaming or watching
youtube how powerful
we got powerful podcasters in general so
you know
the mainstream media is kind of on the
on its way out a little bit like there's
a bit of a tide people just need to be a
little open-minded to it what you were
taught in school and you know all that
stuff because
it it again it goes with this it's like
if you let them make decisions for you
man if they're not making the best
decision for you right they're doing it
because they have a political agenda if
you take a look at like you got russell
brand jimmy dore you have joe rogan in
the middle you have um and then you have
let's say where are you saying russell
brown's left ben shapiro super left ben
shapiro what says tucker carlson all
right all saying the same thing that's a
sign
that like people are starting to come
together
saying the same thing yeah so they're
all starting to come together you know
but the truth of the matter is it's like
if nobody watches the news how's it all
getting out well the next phase is blue
check marks on social media putting out
all this stuff getting all these
retweets it's like all layered [ __ ] then
you really want to get some weird stuff
man
dude ley lines bro if you look at the
world there's an energy grid bro and
there's these ley lines and they're
these power points and that's all you
used to talk about crazy guys
is that a [ __ ] ley line dog and
that's an okay
alignment's drawn between various
historic structures and prominent
landmarks the idea was developed in the
early 20th century europe with ley lines
these alignments were recognized by
ancient societies that deliberately
erected structures along them so look at
the one in there in america what's that
on right there washington dc dude and
what does that mean it amplifies dude
but energy-wise
we just went too deep it's coming out
let's talk about [ __ ] i like it dude
you're getting crazy right now no he was
he was going i was like
bro it's what [ __ ] tesla was into but
i want this to be a fun show i feel like
i get too serious when i come on these
shows that's why i want to talk about
let's make fun of bryce you want to talk
about the party black
yeah we'll do that off camera okay cool
whenever whenever sam and i are doing
the podcast and i and i start to debunk
one of the conspiracies which is never
but it's like even if you talk to a flat
earther which we don't blame flat earth
but you better have your facts
because those flatter
dude you have a real flat earther oh
yeah and they start firing fast yeah
yeah just like a bunch of people it's
round dude you look like a [ __ ] laura
so we got to get brendan props here
because brandon came up with the concept
of conspiracy social club yeah brennan
said i got it i got it it wasn't in the
dark days and he goes sam and you you're
going to do conspiracy sam's going to
debunk it and it's been we've we're
flipped we're on 150th i call it sam
goes
yeah youtube youtube
kicked us off so we had to go from page
12
oh patreon get you updated yeah because
we had we had to go
vimeo vimeo i was like
yeah so we had to go to we had people
vimeo yeah vimeo was pretty like yeah we
were paying for this video oh dude
they're like no
they were like maybe you should do on
only fans they killed it go away well
well then then what we did was we went
to we go to rockfin and we i we just had
uh one of the the ch the former chairman
of the the architects and engineers for
truth for the 911 truth about how you
know and he's saying that the towers
were detonated yeah and to me i'm like
[ __ ] you better have your facts yeah
you got a guy like that he's got videos
slowing [ __ ] down yeah and yeah you're
like by the end of it you're like all
right he's also looking at the
metallurgy of it all and i'm like i mean
jesus christ i'm not a [ __ ] scientist
but you get a nice so i get my [ __ ]
really rude
every show and the comments are like
brian i mean they're so vicious ryan's
not the guy for the gig because he's not
going to break research
i do it on youtube and those guys are
like oh you is that what you're doing
you're doing the first youtube research
that you want me to debunk that it's
like if you get a guy who's like balls
deep in religion right you want to argue
they have their black belt in religion
dude so if you just keep going i need
proof i need dude they like these i've
had those conversations they destroyed
these [ __ ] they not only do
they they have it's a full-time job for
them but here's the crazy people make a
living off of it yeah but here's the
problem when you actually really put
their feet to the fire when you really
go who's really running [ __ ] like i mean
we stop everything i'll go who's really
running [ __ ] if i do that to him or i do
that to some of these big time people
send me i'll give you 50 names i know
the end of it no at the end they'll look
at you and they'll go
either they say this they go rostral
you're not ready yet
look at that or if you really push him
all you'll get is this
starts in buckingham palace yeah and
they go like this and you go wait sam i
want to know or
scientology scientology when you get to
a certain level you're like hey but what
about this they're all you'll see you're
not right can i tell you a joke
you want to hear a fun joke yeah okay so
i know
a satanist a pedophile
a scientologist
and a
nazi walk into a bar what do they do
invent nasa
that's a true story
i mean that's the truth please stop
please stop by the way when i know that
i i don't i don't know about the other
one scientology but i i know for a fact
okay so if i start arguing that i know
ron hubbard helped found nasa but b and
that's why they were dressed like that
all the time and he's talking about
space all the time so dude that's why
he's tax exempt they're making bazillion
dollars that's why disney is tax exempt
making bazillions of dollars dude
because they're all in on them now if i
just don't know why wait now if i
disagree which i do he goes like yeah
how do you disagree with me historical
facts he goes he goes
white girl duncan yeah
what do you disagree on as far as yeah
we know for a fact nazis were involved
with nasa because we took their best and
brightest lines
for you
but it just doesn't mean that nasa is
evil nasa does important work with
weather with space travel okay
we're not arguing so yeah but that
you're very cute
so wait you don't think there was a
landing on the moon
no oh wow
you talking about when we're trying to
beat the russians yeah you're talking
about the one where they landed and a
giant car got out of this tiny ass
go-kart and drove around do you think
that's the satellite hey will you do me
a favor chin will you look up um
will you look up
this is my favorite video really when
you look up the astronauts leaving the
moon nobody ever talks about this see
it's this tough because ryan's brian's
saying no we were telling him he's we're
on the brian so we were on the moon but
what makes you say okay
let me see the video first
you know what else i want to know from
you too because i know their opinion on
it or what they think yeah i want to
know what you think about the kennedy
astronaut oh yeah it was uh this is easy
leaving the moon it was four different
countries it was uh it was the bankers
the mafia the mafia the cia 100 and uh
so you're pretty much on the same page
okay so yeah it's a lot of people yeah
it sounds yeah this guy's saying one
more time
that's what the astronauts leaving the
moon see if you can find that video this
is the cutest thing ever you will laugh
so hard when you see this video
should we do it on i did go on the video
go go to videos and i'll find it for you
you're going to laugh your ass oh that
one where it says apollo 17 lift off
from moon will you go nope down down
over over the other way other there no
there we go watch this this is the
cutest thing you will ever watch in your
[ __ ] life this is what they're
telling you
is the move the astronauts leaving the
moon
[Applause]
he'll watch it swing like a prop there
we go
and how is it lifting off
where is the uh the jet pack
where is
any of that bright and so bright what
they watch you believe this one there
and then this rocket came and hooked up
with it and brought it back to the
planet that's what they want you to
believe you're not so so this is the
video they showed the world yeah but you
don't see so brian ryan this is that
this is the video that showed the world
yeah but yeah it's uh oh brian that
doesn't look good astrophysicists
any degrees i have a degree in
psychology from unlv okay so it's a
psychology dick dude you take the comedy
and you're awesome logically i know
you're [ __ ] up right
that's in my expert opinion
what are we gonna debate on the show
saturday give us something b we have to
debate something yeah we're doing a live
debate show in las vegas i i i listen
when i thought of this show i thought it
was a good idea now that i hear it i
feel like sam's [ __ ] undefeated oh
dude
yeah they show up in big and they are
true believers
i mean i'm just i'm yeah i wonder if
covets beat to death but if you start
with the origins of cove yeah that's oh
yeah we can get into all that that might
mean i'd love to do i think we should
start that because a lot of diving into
fouchy's interesting we can oh yeah we
can get into that we give in the power
base of the world yep which is black
nobility that i'd like to do
because you guys believe
where do you find your information
streets and the streets are talking no
no no no no no real talk about you know
what i think about i'd say
three times a week and this was probably
seven years ago i was doing brian
eddie bravo you were doing brian no
we're doing a uh we're doing a fight
companion and you know eddie was going
on some conspiracy at the time he i just
didn't know and then i was arguing with
him because where do you get your news
from and i said cnn yeah and eddie's had
literally you would see
they separate from the [ __ ]
you went did it take off like that she
goes off the moon
oh my god by the time cnn was not as
crazy like he was kind of you know not
out
yeah
i just i can get into all that too if
you want we could discuss why what has
happened there but yeah man it's like
listen what you do is you do i a lot of
this dude is like feel and energy right
yeah so you have this kind of
understanding about how life works and
then what you do is you ask yourself who
gets the money and who gets the power
if those things line up you're probably
on to something dude my favorite topic
to talk about is hidden history like our
history has been hidden from us meaning
that they don't want us to know how
special we are like dude like those
pyramids like they don't want
they want you to believe they found
sphinx in the fog they they found
[ __ ] all these uh um
all these pharaohs in the in in the
pyramids they've never found a pharaoh
in the pyramid yeah ever the sphinx is
like thousands and thousands of years
older than the pyramids they don't want
you to know any of that and they said
and they don't know how it was concerned
yeah they say they're slaves but they
don't know for a fact
who doesn't want you to know how special
you are dude this powerful group of
people we we know how we know that we
have unlimited capabilities in
technology and we keep doing but you
don't even understand the old technology
blows us out of the water really yeah
they can't explain how the pyramids
would be well just because you can't
explain something doesn't mean that it's
it's yeah but brian like you curious
though yeah of course it does but their
pyramids are way older than they're
telling us okay the egyptians didn't do
the pyramids they moved in so basically
let me tell you about pyramids are
basically like houses in michigan okay
we're just like grizzly bears move in
and they're like this is my house that's
what the egyptians and the mayans all
did with their their their pyramids they
did not build the pyramids they just
moved in they're like how does this work
and they just started trying
and then it just ends up with a human
sacrifice
how do you know that
because brian this is what people are
starting to notice man they're starting
to notice that the pyramids in like peru
are exactly like the pyramids in egypt
meaning they were special they were
closely associated suburbs yeah yeah and
like the world was much different then
you have this this [ __ ] suburb this
great flood that is discussed in all
these cultures yeah yeah right yes they
probably came hit the
planet mess everything up so they're
trying to make it seem like humans
didn't go fully stupid so i can't
articulate it well enough yeah yeah bad
though but it's like dude it's like we
are way more special than they want no
so certain scientific things you would
agree like carbon dating we that carbon
dating has been really effective at
showing the half-life of carbon and
showing how old something is right right
so they found an arctic shark yeah and
they and they could tell by its eye they
did carbonate this is five hundred yeah
but what if it got eye work done like
you uh
what if that shark had its lids done
yeah yeah and they're like we think 500
but he has young eyes
i don't know he had a facelift why is
this gay owl shark
yeah we know the shark was a homosexual
yeah
but it is this is the power bottom shark
right the power but but technology seems
to be moving at an inexorable rate so i
don't know that anybody doesn't want us
to know how special we are like yeah 100
brian but who because they want us to
think wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait they want to control us what
would they get out of what would they
get out of saying the pyramids are
what they get out of this is scarcity
okay what they get out of this is that
they can control us through fear and
they want us to once
for once in your life tell me the least
who is running
dude i've done half a show with him he
gets it i've done 150 episodes with you
and you're still lost yeah this guy's
got like one time i was in a uh a taxi
and this guy was using like waze and
he's and it shows him take a right
though tells her he's like i don't know
where i'm going i'm like dude you're
running that's brian on my show but
online giving his way
instructions
where are we yeah i don't know
all this time
sam so you don't think any of his points
are fair
none like is it when you say the
technology
done no hey hey chapelle of course my my
my um i i deal in logic no brian trusted
the government too much yeah the way he
was raised listen because they were all
his babysitters that's why
i my dad
he calls henry kissinger uncle h that's
what he calls
my dad did work for the deep state now
here's the thing dude and there is a
file on you and and i had them open a
file on you but listen
when you i just want you to say on this
podcast who the [ __ ] you think is
actually calling the shots and running
[ __ ] wow
[ __ ] you i don't need you going like
that all right
shut up
go black nobility who's that they're
basically old banking families that go
all the way back towards um they've been
around forever yeah since uh and they're
running at the show
they're calling their shots why'd you go
rome wrong because that's might be even
be black aristocracy our roman
aristocratic families who started with a
papacy under pope pius the ninth after
the spoiled family-led army of the
kingdom of italy entered rome in 20
september that's not
so it's just it's just a group it's a
group of the most powerful things and
they have all the money in the world
they have dude they have money you don't
you you don't think so so it's like you
don't believe the meaning of this like
the queen no
they're most likely calling the shots
above the queen they're not or yeah the
queen might be high up too like they're
on that level if not like here's the
problem if you know the queen's name she
ain't running [ __ ]
got it okay okay okay okay so you know
you know
yeah okay
you look up do they list the the actual
names of the black nobility they're like
names you never even heard of i doubt it
i know but so so the so the
let me help so just for like you look at
the media conglomerates right you we
know there's powerful people that run
those and have agendas for the news and
have all the funding in the world you
look at flies you look at all those
pharma big farmers big pharma they all
have agendas and they're all very very
powerful we're all talking to each other
yeah yes i would like to say i would
like to talk about mma
chicks so don't you think they're
working out from there being a thick boy
i think what so so what you'd have to
say this sam so let me ask you i just
wanted on the record that i want to talk
about working out and hot chicks and
being a thick boy
and all that stuff all that so when
they're like stop talking [ __ ]
conspiracy just know i'm here to talk
about that but checks this is a much
better [ __ ]
i'm here for the thick [ __ ] yeah i'm
all about amazon [ __ ]
now this is a better question
i'm going to ask you a very specific
question yeah god i hope it's good we
have the we have a we're trying like the
democrats are trying to pass a massive
spending bill right let's
there's an ideological sort of impetus
and also an economic consideration on
that side of the aisle that says we'll
create jobs
it'll um it'll be good for all our
programs and we'll stick a bunch of
other things in there gender politics
and all kinds of stuff inflation it's
like a pork barrel project okay
now we know that they democrats want
that build better better back better i
think there's a progressive an energized
small progressive part of the democratic
party that seems to be hijacking all the
moderates yeah okay cool hijacking we
have pushback from the republicans and
you have independents who are like this
is [ __ ] a lot of insane okay
that is being debated on the floor of
congress right yeah it either gets
vetoed by the president or it gets
passed or it doesn't get passed by the
senate and all that well even when the
democrats right let it pass yeah do you
know that the bla and the same goes in
england the same thing goes in
parliament and england you can hear them
debate debating we know that boris boris
johnson johnson um
has to be you know responsible to his
party
now when they're making decisions like
that that are i'm talking about
trillion dollar decisions yeah yeah two
trillion dollars sure four trillion
dollars a thousand billion dollars in
one trillion dollars yeah no we know
it's big money right who's doing big
math does the
big brain on brian no
now bubba
no one in the vatican or buckingham
palace
no one is able to influence you are so
[ __ ] and the reason they can't is
because
we see it being debated and fought
against and it gets and it doesn't get
passed
the black nobility isn't going and if
they are is somebody from the black
military going yay
nay and then this is all theater yeah it
is yeah because the last time i heard
it's put up to a very public vote yeah
that we're all aware of you're saying
yeah yeah but how do you know that
better how do those agendas go
well sometimes they pass sometimes they
don't right but what i'm saying is that
we know there's a lot of government
waste but i'm saying that but how many
thought but to compete with that like
how all those agendas you talk about how
much follow-through do you see do you
get a report sometimes you see
follow-through it depends on the very
right subject very rarely have you ever
done like a charity show and do you ever
follow up if the money actually went to
the charity
never never never sam do you know you
know you pay the same taxes i do do you
know where your taxes mean i'm in a much
different tax bracket we know that but
i'm just saying
but dude do you know where it's getting
spent do you know no spent no no do you
know the break oh yeah actually i do
dude i know where my tax money goes to
new zealand paying off the [ __ ] money
that we borrow from the federal reserve
that's where all your taxes go
so we can get into that as well if you
want to discuss what do you think about
you have no idea to break down your
taxes no never do never that's one of
the that's one of the criticisms from
libertarians and republicans right but
in a hundred percent and that's a very
very good question right so a lot of it
goes to defense spending a lot of it
goes to um you know things like that
that's what they say government borrows
that money from the federal reserve and
we use our taxes to pay off that money
and there is a small chance that big
chunk goes to the queen of england well
sam who broke that deal was brokered
with ben franklin who they found like a
hundred bodies in his [ __ ] basement
at one point by the way fun facts check
please frank hey guys
i'm gonna ask you something i don't know
exactly that's where i jumped off the
track
yeah look at that no ben franklin did
have a bunch of hoes and dead bodies
they ate a bunch of hoes and writings by
the way everybody dates a bunch of hoes
he was serious there's a time in your
life where hoes are great yeah well if
you're ben franklin yeah it's like [ __ ]
dude yeah the only guys
or guys who can't get hoes yeah you're
right
he was a serial killer uh he was doing
some shady [ __ ] yeah
yeah hey are you are you like stressed
out all the time no dude because i'm
spiritual bro
i was just kidding that was a genuine
question no no
like you know when you have that kind of
information and think about all that
stuff so much and so many things are
just like
out of your control like i would feel
like you're just like no
you'd be stressed out if you're far left
or far right where you believe in that
cause and you dude you're me
[ __ ] yeah okay that makes sense yeah
okay
yeah you still have an answer nobody can
control you dude
nobody can control you right now what
about the black the black mobility again
what apparently well they can control
they can control the levers of power but
at the end of the day but how do they
control a vote sam well a vote is a vote
right brian are you asking if they can
rig a vote or not i mean are you really
right in your crooked mouth thank you
dude you don't think they can control
votes in congress thank you
so brian
you don't think what brian are you just
baffled no no
oh my god how can you could control
corrupt people
let me give you one better because the
ballots the mail and balance
real oh
i wonder why there is a there is
absolutely um the problem in washington
which is that
fundraisers might be pulling the strings
oh because when you're in congress
because of campaign finance reform in
congress to run for office you got to
make certain people who finance your
campaign campaign happy right of course
right that's it they all get compromised
so you can believe it it's on us a
micro level you can't believe it on a
macro level do you think there ever be a
change but oh yeah it's coming sam i
don't think pluto's in the high house
dog but i don't think that's a mystery i
think that isn't that isn't that just
well pluto is death and then a rebirth
and they know this so they're trying to
get ahead of it and they're going to
[ __ ] lose what happened what do you
mean
so pluto the last time pluto was in our
orbit and stuff like that it was during
the civil war and pluto represents
and death to the old i remember this and
into the news what does that mean we're
all going to die no that means [ __ ] a
new yeah
i'm following this we got to sacrifice
brian brian zach you couldn't get much
for a sacrifice for brian
ryan's sacrifice i'm doing it i died
sacrifice the senior citizens nobody's
doing that
well coveted said all right is 3.7
billion miles away from the sun well
that's so far away what the [ __ ] it's
still so far away
wait are you into astrology bro
dude what do you got astrology
saying dog there's an old saying
millionaires study the market
billionaires study the [ __ ] stars
i mean there are the billionaires are
trying to get up there right well dude i
mean this is my old theory right they're
all trying to average people want to be
millionaires millionaires want to be
billionaires billionaires won't be
trillionaires and trillionaires won't be
darth vader that's why it's going poor
men want to be rich rich man want to be
king and the king ain't satisfied until
he rules everything yeah there you go
dog
ten points for where that's from
ten points uh ice cube
ice cube lethal weapon no nwa thrones
okay
poor man want to be rich rich man one
king and a king
neil young bruce bruce
hey real quick you know neil young's
music's back on spotify no
yeah did he realize that he was kind of
wrong according to the israeli
australian debate data coming out on i
don't know it's not bring it up on your
phone that's all article is it yeah
young so is it the other people who are
going to pull up backtrack yeah uh i
mean
yeah
no he doesn't i heard
i heard beethoven's threatening
his music still it's not on there no
it's on there bro this is the only thing
i'm on neil young okay
let me let me br so some i'm not saying
his entire catalog because he sold his
catalog for 150 million dollars but the
one that was on there that was trying to
get off is still on there some of neil
young's music quietly stayed at spotify
amid joe rogan protest
oh [ __ ]
so it's only is that our dictionary only
only friends all those can i know but if
you want all you i thought you were
taking all your music off yeah bubba
what happened i thought i thought you
were anti-spotify it's all theater to
amazon
i love that he's like get off spotify go
to amazon that's where the love happens
yeah i think it's amazing that dr
malone's been banned from twitter for
spreading covet misinformation and uh if
you could tell me what misinformation
i'd appreciate it well that's the whole
thing dude it's like what is
misinformation there's weapons of mass
destruction in iraq at one point that
was considered to be some kind of fact
right yeah and now the [ __ ] with hillary
coming out so funny i want to see you
thinking about that whole middle east
war and the weapons of mass destruction
it was only 20 years ago it was only
like 20 years dude yeah how crazy is
that they might even what's the the
homie who just passed away brilliant man
what's his name he just passed away
though
no man captain kangaroo no the guy in
the government and he was the vice
president he was with bush
um
um colin powell
yeah yeah so and he said that was the
biggest defense yeah
that's my biggest regret
you know buying into that thing he's a
reptilian yeah no he knew because he was
a military guy and he hated with that he
said he went with me because it's my
biggest regret like on his deathbed he's
like you wish you never did that yeah
yeah
yeah the thing about the soda yeah
misinformation like a [ __ ] do
you ever hear that there might be a
stargate in iraq and that was the
weapons of mass destruction which is uh
uh well well how about how about the
fact that the covenant the ark of the
covenant which was held by the by the
israelites and it was it was considered
it's from regis to the lost ark like any
army that holds the ark of the covenant
was unbeatable and they think the
original ark the archicad of the
covenant might be in a coptic church in
ethiopia
and it's still there and it's solid gold
and the reason they thought it was
powerful as it might have well
radioactively
well they've done a lot of things you
believe that [ __ ] but you won't believe
sam's stuff i'm just saying sam are you
a flat earther no i'm a realm guy
meaning
that this is a very special place
is this is this a simulation that this
is the lowest level of heaven highest
level of hell there's multiple
dimensions
where'd you come up with that and
everything is
the world's ran by sorcerers
it is we're all magicians absolutely
some of us are better than others
like i'm watching babylon five or
something yeah if you're in a simulation
then it's just like when they i hate
when and
only like billionaires they were in a
simulation like the guy at mcdonald's
like yeah man making these fries in a
simulation though like it's only super
super rich people have this crazy guilt
because they see other people suffering
like it's a simulation though you do
wonder i guess you do wonder if there
were certain people in history that were
put there like so it's like if i go back
and kill hitler well here's the thing
about hitler hitler's nickname he's a
great dancer hitler and hitler in world
war one his nickname was lucky
because he was dying multiple there's so
many stories about his buddies they
would stand next to him because bullets
just seen you know you really wonder if
he was a devil like he had no because
also with him like if they would just
give him that arch scholarship there's
no [ __ ] world war ii that's right if
you just gave charles maynard
school of hearts for the viewers alive
ever get into that stuff
which one where you you go charles
manson yeah you're live what do you got
yeah i'll give my black belt charles
well i'm with you on all that dude
charles manson was basically a cia
player correct and that i hate ashby
ashbury was a free-range psychological
experiment to see what crystal meth and
psychedelics would do to somebody told
me that and his parole officer
there's a reason like when he was on the
ranch which is spawn ranch which i drive
by all the time i ride my bike there and
i've been in the cave and all that [ __ ]
when he was on spawn ranch they were
very aware that the police were there
where i did and someone went to them and
was like hey this guy has bodies on that
[ __ ] spawn ranch he's a bad dude he
has a family out there and the cop
specifically said on record goes we're
not allowed to touch him
where he he like he basically has a free
pass his parole because it was an fbi
investigation no no no no no because he
was a cia player
yeah that's what they think because he
got away with so much [ __ ] for so long
even the parole officer when they went
to him he wasn't allowed to leave hey
that's why because they wanted to create
a war against the counter culture
hippies
they wanted to do an experiment so they
would do these free clinics and everyone
would be like oh man it's a free clicker
well his girls would go in the clinic
because they had so many stds and he
would go on that he had him so in order
for him to like get power he would bring
his girls to you know to the beach boys
house or whatever and be like yeah [ __ ]
my girls man like this guy's great then
he again with them but if that stds it
wouldn't work so they always go to this
clinic
and hate ashby and the clinics were a
cia uh hidden operation to get gathered
data what was that that's you know i've
heard that first of all
morrison being a cia plant well his dad
was part of the gulf of tonkin yeah but
jim morrison never really and that was
during the and i was yeah brian you act
like talented people came but no
the rumor is that he wasn't actually
singing those songs oh for [ __ ] sake
jim morrison was singing this song well
there's a rumor but back in the day when
they said i'm not saying when they go
see him live
most a lot of people complain yeah who
is who is singing some cia guy i mean no
come on brian jim morrison brian and
listen i'm a big doris fan
you know but i heard i heard that rumor
as well like that right because
his dad was what
dude i'll tell you another one i guess
it's a conspiracy or it's just facts
samuel is courtney love clearly murdered
kurt cobain dude it's clear allegedly
allegedly right have you ever looked
into her story she was a cia plant who
was brought in to bring drugs to the
scene so she did in europe and then they
brought her here and she did it she did
she introduced heroin basically seattle
sam nobody needed the cia to introduce
heroin human beings have been doing
drugs and psychedelics for heroin was
over-the-counter i know look at crack
what are you talking about i mean they
introduced crack to the black community
human beings have been doing drugs in
one form or another and drinking opium
yes
historically like even the indiana mono
and people in in
brazil were taking psychedelics i mean
this is not drug culture they weren't
making human beings have always altered
their states from time and memorial
education right so so look at look at
alcohol so brian americans there was a
time where drugs were all legal and what
they did is they made it illegal so that
that they could create a black market in
which the
crazy [ __ ] before we figured it out but
no it wasn't over the counter okay so my
whole theory is this
is that the cia
and organized crime are
are
two sides of the same coin fair okay
so we go back to we go back
to when
the uh nazis were brought over now you
think that the nazis lost and that they
were brought over i think the nazis won
the war germany lost the war they
destroyed germany and the nazis walked
over do they live in the center of the
earth no they just walked some did yes
well no they went to they went to
operation high jump they also went to
south america yeah like you like that's
where kennedy yeah he wouldn't agree
like tim kenny went to south america and
he's like dude i would walk in the
middle of the [ __ ] jungle it looks so
german well he goes first of all their
first language is german yeah like even
now like they only speak german
he's like
yeah everyone's like what the hell i
mean what didn't nietzsche's uh say
celebrate oktoberfest well nietzsche's
sister
sister founded founded
an anti-semitic colony down and i think
it was paraguay or uruguay she founded
an anti-semitic colony and it was a lot
of like austrians and germans brian
whenever you talk about nazis god bring
up anti-semitism he just gets water
that's what it was that's what the nazis
were they so
so they walked over there they went to
the vatican right they came over here
they they took the oss turned it into
the cia right so if you take a look at
that sam i have to stop you the cia was
an american
group of people patriots no they took
this oss
cia
right
cia has a lot of patriots like the fbi
i'm not saying it's called
compartmentalizing certain people need
to know
certain people don't need to know
for a guy who has never really been in
the cia you seem to have a lot of inside
information there's a lot of people
because the people i know work for the
cia are not that impressed with the cia
so brian your contacts yeah a lot of
them are like i told you one more like
this they're like well i've been in
those rooms dude and i'm going to tell
you right now it's not that impressive
brian's so funny like we'll be arguing
banking he'll call a banker up who
sounds exactly like dracula yeah he'd be
like blah blah dance
banking's fine blah blah blah
i called somebody who knows some [ __ ]
about the federal reserve and he goes
yeah but he was like but they're in the
game they're on the team nobody's like
well you got to step right it's like
it's like from china like hey or north
korea like hey how's everything going
out there like fantastic like see it's
great there yeah but the guy's talking
the guy's talking and sam's like
this guy
what do you have a [ __ ] track
he's like but he's like really busy he
goes who the [ __ ] is talking and that
guy's trying to explain it technically
his hand's going seems like who the [ __ ]
is dracula you can't call dragon and the
guy's talking he's going blah blah blah
i drink her blood the guy's like i gotta
[ __ ] you know we gotta we gotta protect
sam at all cause sam is a if he's like
in hot tub time machine he's a 90s comic
who's ruthless and he's a savage yeah
yeah and there's this he's the best
there's not many laughs
there's not many of you left yeah sam is
[ __ ] sam hilary we are protect him at
all costs yeah and you need to get your
cuck ass
and start buying into some of this man
you know what he's had he's got me he i
got to tell you something have you
gotten them once without getting any
misinformation
yeah he's got me like this
pandemic thing and sam's point of view
on it has got me
he's got me
he's nudging me over
you know he's nudging me over a little
bit
i mean i'm i'm starting to realize yeah
you know when you look at dopesick when
you look at do you know about the do you
watch dope sick dude i haven't seen it
yet that's the whole you watch that and
you have to see how our people can be
compromised when you realize that we're
big money big money can cause good
people to behave in a very bad way yep
and and that is i think the biggest
threat to everything is big
quote big anything big tech when you
have [ __ ] companies like amazon uh
controlling this much when they own when
jeff bezos owns the washington post when
he owns like the means of
information when he can control the
server even more so
think about facebook you think about the
agenda with twitter and facebook and
that's where
most young people in the the population
is getting their news from twitter not
facebook anymore no not facebook well my
thing is still facebook
face facebook still has the most
demographic they have the most
subscribers grandmas
but they still have the most subscribers
still pretty powerful but then twitter
that's where a lot of people are getting
their news from on that feed
so you got to think about what like
what's their agenda on that news feed
that's educating the public my thing is
like what what is not what we're not
hearing but we're not hearing stuff like
that's what really drives me crazy the
legacy media doesn't report on important
[ __ ] because it grates against their
narrative when was the last time when
was the last time you read anything
about afghanistan did we just forget
about it i guess i guess biden pulls out
and i'm i'm sure they're doing great i
was taking heat for like about maybe
three days and they just went away it's
like it went away and if it goes away
have you talked to any military people
about that oh you know what else they
did
they just pulled funding for afghanistan
and now they're like we're holding on to
it and we're deciding what to do with
the money we're gonna give a big chunk
of it to the families of 9 11. i'm like
afghanistan had nothing to do with 911
why are we doing this why are you
punishing people yeah that had not i
mean we've already established this
they were not a part of 9 11. it wasn't
afghanis it wasn't afghanistan the
saudis yeah and a couple other people
that make brian uncomfortable correct
well he's who i want to talk about other
stuff like so i think they don't read
the comment section they're going to be
like
i want to talk about a fun cool [ __ ]
like this is fun cool [ __ ] though
all day i just don't want you guys
getting mad at me i've learned a lot
nobody lets me on their show anymore i'm
like nobody lets rudolph playing the
reindeer games
so it's finally nice to be allowed to
dance with the pretty girls do you do
you still talk to eddie a bunch all the
time yeah so sam i tried to get eddie
undercover bro i love you really i miss
him man i do we still talked about once
a week i'll just take some mischief bro
and then he'll just send me [ __ ] you
know he's got a couple of things that
i'm helping him with yeah he's the best
he is the best the best he's jiu-jitsu
jesus yeah and i'll tell you this i go
on the road with him
i'm gonna tell you and this a i'm not
exaggerating if that dude focused on
stand up he would literally be one of
the funniest people working today
like not just generally like literally i
believe it todd top 10. he's always very
funny like dude every time i hang out
with him he has a new 10-minute story
that i've never heard before yeah and
it's the funniest [ __ ] you've ever heard
and if he just could go somewhere and
fine-tune it he would be dropping comedy
eddie is such a good person actually
eddie in his heart and he's very unique
yeah he's one of a kind he's very unique
and he isn't afraid to go against the
grain and that's kind of in this day i
mean the biggest thing with all this
stuff going on that there's a lot of
people now that have a permanent record
of their stance on some stuff yeah and
the future it's i think it's gonna be
very bad for them
because
they're on the wrong side you gotta be
on team humanity yes a non-team power
structure yep and he's had this long
like history of like
when everybody listen i'm a zigger okay
i mean everyone zags isaac no be careful
yeah i was like why i like being a
singer okay oh whoa damn huh
[Laughter]
i see word you know
people say by the way
yeah
we live in a very we're living in a
really weird time
it hasn't always been like this like in
the 70s with the hippie movement it was
like chaos in vietnam
in the 90s you had a you know the only
there's a difference iraq the only
promise there's a difference like um
information gets to a billion people
that fast and that's so much fake [ __ ]
out there yeah so information in general
can and they influence do you ever watch
foreign time before kings i told you
about it what's it about it's about
duran
hearns hagler and um and ray leonard so
it's super interesting but they
juxtaposed the boxing versus the
politics at the time and if you watched
politics at the time you know what
they're complaining about a democratic
president that no one has faith in high
prices of gas
inflation unemployment
nobody's working you know it's all the
same thing crimes crime was up like
crazy
riots right
racial strife it's dude this is people
are starting to realize this is this
game play so these lizard people they
can't come up with original ideas that's
why they just keep using like hollywood
they keep regurgitating the game
no dude it's not they're lizards and
they're not human beings we might all be
humans and everybody's
vying for power there's parasites that
run this realm one or the other
it could go either way but i'm just
saying it could also just be their
parasites
to get society to move you know like
we're sheep so they know what prod
somebody comes up with jesus was a
shape-shifter i understand but some
people come up with technologies like
amazon and it changes how we do amazon
is the us government jeff bezos is an
actor his father started his grandfather
started darpa they put him in position
and he's just an actor so so jeff bezos
didn't create nope
it was created by darpa he's not a guy
who he's nope just like facebook you
know the story of facebook
you know the story
he dropped out of harvard created
facebook yeah but he didn't he didn't
create facebook he stole it from those
no two brothers that's all that's all
theater [ __ ] yeah it's a good movie
though i don't know i like it it was
okay so steve jobs
steve jobs might be but they all steal
their they're all steal the [ __ ] bill
gates is full don't get me started yeah
don't get me started on bill gates right
you're lucky there's two stick boys
between us
very smart guy who created microsoft no
not didn't happen
his mother stole the operating system
from ibm gave it to him she stole it
yeah she just stole it and gave it to
her but her son now son took it and was
like ah now i make billions of dollars
there you go so that all it required was
so if he had given it to me i could have
done the same thing yeah wait what's the
facebook story facebook okay so when you
look up life log will you look up this
life log was a uh uh
a pentagon
operation that they were creating
technology that would collect your data
for your entire life
so so will you look up so darpa life was
happening so will you look up this what
day did the government stop the life log
uh experiment what day darpa created
okay real quick you're gonna love this
brian you're gonna love this brian's so
great he's taking repeated else right
now so life log you are like experiment
stopped um what day does it say what day
it is
february 4th 2004. okay will you look on
what day facebook was registered as an
uh a business will you look up that yeah
wait go back go back let's talk about
let them do this real quick and find
this before you start cancel the
lifelong project on the same day that
mark zuckerberg okay you ruined my my
fun of reveal
you are the worst
do not understand presentation big
killer jones over here yeah when you go
to magic shows it's not really a rabbit
it's not really covered in house
an illusion
so yeah so that that was exactly you're
saying when they stopped then that's
when literally the same day
convenience isn't that uh isn't that a
coincidence is it a coincidence well i
we know that darpa is not a surprise
that darpa the technology for the
internet was created by barbara right
right so it was gps so it's do you find
it amazing brian that amazon pays no
taxes to the u.s government which by the
way the irs is not part of the us
government do you find that kind of
crazy seattle i mean washington has been
criticized for that for being a
regressive the new yorker
hey now think about this if amazon is
part of the us government why would the
us government pay taxes to the u.s
government but amazon is
is i mean they're shareholders
oh wait a minute hold on as a private
citizen if i buy if i buy shares of
amazon wait let it work
i get rich very serious but if i buy
shares of amazon it's a publicly traded
company now yeah to be private now it's
public yeah so jeff is worth a crazy
amount of money
200 billion dollars supposedly so
so i i
i can own pieces of
amazon right yeah that doesn't and if i
own pieces of the us government right
bond it pays a much lower dividend than
amazon right brian it's about amazon
stock right now well what i'm saying is
that yeah it's very different so how are
you saying amazon's part of the us
government part of the u.s government
well it's an extension of the u.s
government part of the reason
for their taxes on twitter that's how
google google was started by uh by
started by
cia
no it was started by two russians no it
wasn't two mathematicians they were
picked but somebody had to come burning
man burning man is the new bohemian girl
where all the [ __ ] elites go get they
shove weird [ __ ] and butts okay and
that's how you get into the elites
sam sergey prince and mary page
mary page and sergey brin are the
mathematicians that came up with the
algorithm they're they they were they
they're right brian oh yeah brian the
google yeah yeah brian prove it yeah
prove it brian is that what you read on
google yeah the google tell you that
does google talk like dracula too you
must think that cia in the darpa is the
only place technology comes out of is
that what you think no i'm just saying
that stuff that gets that big
like pornhub is cia too
well that's not good
some of them sometimes people come up
with a technology individual yeah
pornography use because it's better like
only fans like only fans like amazon
like
like patreon porno cia it's it went zero
to 50 million
subscribers quicker than any other
company all the big technology so all of
big tech all those entrepreneurs yeah in
in san francisco the big big ones all of
those guys they're the big big ones
we're all cia operatives yeah then it's
all theater yeah well they were
presented because they they were a
character yeah how did they pull that
off because the tax base is huge down
there that's what kept san francisco
afloat yeah so really yeah brian cia
yeah
cia they must be the best entrepreneurs
in the world sam bryant all that
technology came down to me 100
brian
this this phone is all cia yeah yeah
really not most of the result of the
capitalist system no steve jobs most of
it steve drop swipe technology so much
of it yeah it was what which i've worked
it out which is
which is that it's a cl a data
all the money they've made what how do
you account for all the money well
because they they they basically corner
the market brian
what's that they corner the market
and now you're addicted to that thing
yeah
now they know all the weird [ __ ] you're
jerking off too brian a lot of companies
which is owls [ __ ] but a lot of
comments
but a lot of companies went out of
business bubba
when yeah but they didn't did that
facebook didn't
right facebook never did something
everybody right
isn't it kind of crazy that facebook can
just sell your [ __ ] data and never
get in trouble and that's how they made
their [ __ ] money by selling your
[ __ ] data
so you're saying it's just quinky dink
that the [ __ ] facebook and life log
have that date together that jeff
bezos's grandpa is the guy who [ __ ]
founded darpa these just weird
connections all the time sure oh you
don't think that's where the phone has
all your data and they can access you
and also track you everywhere
that is something that's talked about
all the time yeah
data brokers yeah sell your data we all
know this and it comes up in congress
all the time like this is ridiculous
this is crazy and nothing happens
because but that's that is a side effect
and a negative one of the technology
that seems to be growing at an
exponential rate this is this is it's
not all entrepreneurial spirit in this
country and individuals who are really
in in genius don't come out of the cia
sam they some of them are probably some
don't like the guys that create the silk
road you know what happens to him well
he went to jail yeah yeah he also
yeah but if you ever look into that case
he was responsible for putting by the
way do you know that
uh the founder of bitcoin satoshi
nakamoto yeah his name in japanese
loosely translate to central
intelligence but you know that
does it really yeah
that nobody knows who he is
nobody knows who that is
i have no clue who that is
look up what it means yeah let's yeah
satoshi nakamoto good luck spelling that
chin satoshi satoshi satoshi satoshi
there you go
first thing that pops up okay loosely
translated
translates to central
knowledge or intelligence why not yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so a
loosely translates it's a forum so it's
not the best yeah it loosely translates
to central knowledge we are thinking
quitted wise that's what it means
knockout inside will you do that
japanese
yeah make sure you highlight loosely i
know brian because according to god
forbid they come out and say the founder
of bitcoin is central intelligence sam
the cia isn't inventing everything yeah
yeah you don't think any any person like
just like you and i like have the
ability well no no no no no i do think
like artists is the name satoshi loosely
translates to intelligent history
central central hotels there we go so uh
no like google was started by a bunch of
guys but the truth of the matter is is
that they got a ton of funding from a
dummy corporation that the cia ran
okay
so now they have all of your [ __ ]
so have you ever seen the have you ever
seen the videos there's a series of
videos called the dead internet no okay
dude you gotta look into [ __ ] that
are people dying and [ __ ] in there no
the internet's actually dead
that most of the people on twitter and
all these aren't even real people
but the real thing is this hey will you
do it will you go to google put in
let's put in um any term you want chin
i'm gonna let you pick it whatever term
you want in that search bar
fishing okay anything you want
well chin cares about this okay so
fishing go to the bottom the bottom go
to the bottom where it says how many
things how many
hits they got go down does it where does
it say that let's go to the top go down
go to top see if it says it where it
says how many about the time okay about
200
what is that two million
billion
billion okay so go back down to the
bottom
now go to the bottom now go to
go to 10 hit 10 at the bottom to search
10. or hit page 10. yeah go page 10.
okay so keep going down so we're gonna
have 200 2 billion go to 14
just keep going
just go to 14 go to 14 go to 18. go to
wherever you can go to la is that the
last button go to that button right
there see if you can hit that last
button the last the 22.
yeah see what's the weird um
arrow next to it right okay
stop we're at 22. it says there's 22.8
billion from so now that's what it says
repeat the search with omitted
[ __ ] with
results included okay so click on that
real quick
okay click on that so now go all the way
down on the bottom
go do this again
say we're at 10
go down we're at 14
go down we're at 18 just keep going keep
going 22
go to it okay
go to it 25
25
go to the bottom 30. trust me on this
one we'll kind of get to it
trust me
keep going
keep going
it's gonna get my point is this
it's gonna end so it's not gonna be
close to two it's what they they call
this a potential village meaning which
means it's all theater google wants you
for six forty four it's up to four forty
six it stops at forty six right ten
websites a page right can you yeah
it's a total lie they make you think
this is all powerful
it's a big do you know what petunkan
village is sure does okay so there was
this russian czar that wanted to impress
this british royalty who this this queen
or princess that was coming made a fake
village so he made a completely fake
village north korea does it right and
they're like oh look how amazing russia
is so he could marry her
turns out it was all fake now this is
not my research look up the dead
internet
i sam so but but the [ __ ] internet is
pretty
massive
like what they're not as expensive
yeah it's not even close i mean you just
got educated most of your links now your
older links
don't even work bro they do that purpose
billions of hits this is 1984. sam there
are so many people using the [ __ ]
internet for everything it's massive
beyond your imagination fine why are
they telling you there's two point eight
billion five years
44 who cares why because it's all
theater no
it's because it's that big no because
there are that many hits to this point
there wasn't 200 or there were 2.8
billion
so they're just coming up with ways to
make google bigger no they want you to
make it they want you to think that it's
like the biggest thing everybody uses
google all over the world
okay and why are they lying
they're not lying they just lie to you
the internet is
almost infinite it's actually infinite
no it's not infinite but it is no it's
not it's it's not nearly as big as you
think it is
what is that what are you saying i'm
saying
that it's a giant theater that so much
of what's on social media is a giant lie
that they [ __ ] give you retweets and
likes when you algorithm says you say
what they like and then they bombard you
and they [ __ ] just send you to shadow
band hell when you say something they
don't like it's all theater
there's a lot of that going on yeah but
that doesn't mean that you just prove
that with that terrible experiment
what do you mean that terrible
successful experiment yeah there was
definitely not 2.8 billion
links on there i mean so wait that so
that thing at the top of the 2.8 that
was saying how many links there
is right
how many hits well yeah search results
are hits i think search results which
are hits right how many hits they got
four figures and that only ended at 47.
okay there's no way there's no way
there's no way that was but brian
i mean
it was weird it was it was so weird yeah
but i didn't like insane this is where
it starts getting super crazy it's
because people start going uh what's
going on i get it no
matter how i'm done silence oh yeah
sorry guys just because you can't
silence right now it doesn't matter
he just did this is he just explaining
anything there this is the every choice
because at the base of what he's saying
is he's going most of the internet might
be dead it might not be real and this is
my dad
billions of people aren't using it in
every second
well you're wrong yeah they are okay
brian yeah just everyone uses the
internet like we are right now telling
you so what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
uh in real time you saw yeah
wait this is in real time hold on does
my gps work sam anywhere in the world
because it does doesn't it doesn't work
everywhere in the world there's
something
times where it says cannot connect right
brian why can i get from point a to
point b well brian does it work
everywhere you go yeah why does google
maps allow me to see your house if i put
it in what do you what do you what do
you mean what does that approve of
anything all this technology in my phone
yeah has freed me and i want you to see
a lot was it free just you're saying now
they're trying to keep things how are
they going to keep it going
it sounds like it's made your life
busier you're a prisoner i understand
but how do they keep people from how do
they keep any secrets it's so hard brian
they do it all the time they're actually
getting rid they're going back and
getting rid of old websites that they
don't want you to see all the time
google 1984
the ministry of truth google's a
technology they've gotten so rich
because google's the technology we all
use just like oil's technology it's a
sub is a material we're addicted to yeah
there are certain things that we just
use because it makes our lives it's
revolutionary it changes everything we
use cassette tapes
lazy but we don't use
dvds or cds anymore because we have
digital technology right yeah so now we
put our specials on that or we put it on
youtube things just change right and a
lot of it is allowing us to decentralize
and make our own money have our own uh
audience
there's a lot about
technology right that is giving human
beings average everyday citizens their
own autonomy right their own way of
making money and we all know it's true
that a lot of this technology has
enslaved us but the idea that this being
planned by some small group or it's just
a byproduct like everything of
technology as it moves ahead
it does it causes problems solves
problems causes problems that's kind of
how
what side are you arguing for right now
because you're you seem to be saying
because you every time i talk this is
brian every time i talk to you
every time i talk to you as far as
you're concerned there's a small group
of people controlling all of this
and that jeff bezos and elon musk and
mark zuckerberg aren't even real
entrepreneurs they're
actors probably placed by the cia is the
most ridiculous
it is the most ridiculous [ __ ] i have
ever heard in my life right you know
what you want to talk about theater that
is the craziest [ __ ] i've ever heard
yeah elon musk isn't an entrepreneur
isn't it on that tv was kind of nuts too
well
that's fair
i go you were on mad tv yeah he's fair
that's somebody had a bad day at casting
oh the comment section i won that
and by the way i want it fully known i
can talk about anything
fat asses it always comes back to right
tattoos
on faces whatever dude you like to face
tattoos i would i do as long as it's i'm
very nervous because
if it's done right it could be cool
tell them what your weakness is with a
woman's face like i love [ __ ]
slightly cross-eyed
and big teeth
it's weird
i made like slightly a little bit cry
not full-on like
but like just uh one lazy [ __ ] no no not
lazy little crazy and it can't be out
this way it's that's why you know they
got to be here
slightly in fish
and then you like big teeth huh big
choppers i love big teeth do you like
the big gums or i like big teeth big
jaws amazon chicks
like big girls yeah i like viking
[ __ ]
gives a convention all right just gonna
process it i'm just saying
i'm seeing if there's like a thing you
know there's always a thing with people
if there's people that are attracted to
crosstalk yeah i'm really into it
so a man was on a race in bakersfield
where he was riding his bike the race is
called the rock cobble when in the
middle of it he was hit by a bull oh
my god did he die no he did not he's
fine in a lot of pain but he's fine
jesus
i would i feel like you could have
chilled out a little bit
why would he go straight into it
why are you still driving at it that's
what i'm exactly oh
don't get up by the way in that
situation you're supposed to stay down
you don't get up or just run into the
water dude this is what i call thinning
the herd yeah
that's his that's his territory how
scary would that be at this point but
also why would you take don't give up i
get it if you're in a bike race but why
the [ __ ] would you go past the i know i
know
well
yeah take last place
but also your competitors can't also
like you like how do you like he saw the
bull
like this is something straight up he's
like he's straight up
straight up super mario okay go up janet
says uh there were reportedly a total of
four riders attacked in the race
though it appears tony got it the worst
oh my god that's like us doing a tough
mudder just getting [ __ ] just
everyone getting [ __ ] up god damn man
hey make sure that it's a bull free zone
yeah that's the whole thing about nature
too right everyone's like nature's so
loving right it's like people hate the
zoo i'm like you know treats animals
worse than the zoo mother nature
[ __ ] up animals oh did you see that
that biker in africa where that antelope
[ __ ] hits him in mid oh yeah yeah we
saw this video oh [ __ ] that's familiar
oh never mind he's just running what's
that the faces of death gazelle no he
just drugs him there is a 37 year old
indonesian man who went to the er
because he said that he was having some
issues with his lower abdomen he said
there was a lot of pain and upon doing
an x-ray the doctors asked like oh
what's your sexual history maybe it
could be like std because something that
has to do with his penis he says no i'm
a virgin and they found a six
foot long nylon string in his urethra
yeah so he would get erect and stick
this string into it and six feet of it
they had to remove it in order to
alleviate his pain why would you stick
your [ __ ] how can you put six feet
how to [ __ ] this i don't know where does
it go hey have you guys heard that like
20 something of the
of
people in this country haven't had sex
in a year
oh yeah like people are just getting
weird now like they're just bored
they're isolated they don't know how to
talk to each other they're just shoving
[ __ ] up their dicks that's trouble
that's trouble and that's that's society
i couldn't think
like this guy's never had anything
coming out of the penis he's only been
shoving stuff up to the penis but
six feet six feet that's a lot my friend
and he would show us like people put
things in their ass all the time all the
time problems just picks
weird stuff poor gerbils they put a lot
of stuff in there yeah they put like
bleach containers in their ass yeah what
yeah it's a prison wallet yeah it's a
prison wallet
prison purse gold bullion what a sketch
in here
so jeff bezos has a super yacht that he
i believe it's created somewhere in
europe and he has to sail it back to
america and the only way he could get it
to his destination is by going through a
dutch port in the city of rotterdam a
lot of the residents are unhappy with
this because the boat is so big that
they have to dismantle their bridge
temporarily and then put it back
together in order for his boat they're
gonna charm 650 million yeah so he's
paying for this service but a lot of
locals are saying hey let's stop by the
port and throw eggs at him while he's
passing so there are currently you know
you're just going to go inside this
giant yacht while you throw so sam that
is that seems to be his money or is that
all right that's what happens when you
play ball
well you might like his girl she has a
wiggly eyes oh you know what she likes
wiggles leonardo capper yeah
that's who doesn't though yeah now his
ex-wife i was looking for her
i was i'm bumble i was down
yeah me too i do too i do i think she's
cute what are you talking about she's
cute
she's got those teeth too no
i mean dude she's obviously in her cure
phase right there
well once they became billionaires they
got her teeth fixed
dude she got bigger oh brian you're
telling me jeff bezos is not a sniper
with that one eye always shut like that
how many people he's killed you don't
know [ __ ] dude dude how much money does
she get
uh she's rich she's the rich woman in
the world and i think at the time she
was the third richest person in the
world
from the divorce she's cute right there
yeah big t i can't believe she just
didn't go and start banging nba players
right you got all that i might be doing
it just hang out at paying them madison
square garden just be like you you i
want a rainbow bang bang bang bang bang
bang
bang
bang
bang
bang
bang
bang
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
bang bang bang bang dunk your nuts in my
mouth she's cute
what else you got
wait so sam do you like the teeth or the
oh yeah
she's a little
if a girl was like i want i'd get
serious about her relationship and she
came back with some fat teeth i'd be
very excited
[Music]
let them [ __ ] up buying big chompers
yeah let a lot of them have and black
nobility i mean it's just you know this
is a terrible one sad one oh
but uh oh my god dude it is australia
this is austria so it's a shark attack
but it's blurred out but someone filmed
it as a swimmer got just demolished what
a shark yeah
shark that they believe is a great white
yeah they believe it's great you've seen
it no i said i gotta steal oh yeah i
definitely want to see it it's blurred
out so we can watch it it's a shark let
me see
people just filming throw your [ __ ]
phone at the shark you'll see the blood
and the jumping of the you see right
there that's a great one oh some man oh
no
you can't like oh no
oh [ __ ]
they gotta get eaten like a seal like
like basically eaten yeah you said they
would just attack and they leave
it's blurred
you gotta be like stevo what were you
thinking when you jumped in with them oh
no you see the blood there right oh you
see that you see the birds flying around
birds always fly around when uh fish are
attacking other little bait fish because
they're just trying to eat yeah but also
if you're bystander you're not jumping
in the water no of course it's clearly
over so they're still investigating it
they're not sure they saw what they
found are they going to press charges
they're just trying to find out exactly
what happened why why is he swimming
that far into the you know outside the
shore too in queensland or in austin
it's in australia
do they know who it was i'll show you no
so they're still investigating they only
found remains oh yeah yeah he jumped out
of the water now who is this the chick
no no it's a previous shark attack or
something we don't know what the guy
looks like no oh she got attacked before
yeah how about something yeah nature
decides you look nervous she's swimming
with sharks never mind she's going down
oh they don't have anything i don't know
why but that seems pretty tacky to be
like oh this
shark and here's some celebrities
hanging out with sharks i know dude well
you're just like us it's pretty wild it
doesn't surprise me somebody finally got
a real shark attack on on
camera and usually the sharks will taste
it and they'll leave it alone but this
one looked like it actually tried to
just eat it no that one he there was
just shark we came out yeah just like
the way
they don't like
but don't you feel that when you when
you swim for that long in those waters
where there are great whites everywhere
it's a matter of time that is bound to
happen right it's bound to be splashing
around your odds are definitely going
off yeah [ __ ]
i mean like that the worst way possible
worse way shoot me i mean and you got to
realize he's not afraid i guess he's
like uh you know so the really shitty
part is in the article i read like he
you hear him screaming of course before
yeah the question oh so he felt all that
dude yeah yeah well yeah it's terrifying
i think you know oh nothing scarier sir
a great white comes from like jaws that
was out of draw that was i would shout
sure
wherever it is brian when it bit you
would it be like uh too leathery let you
go
oh weird i don't like beef jerky yeah
they say
rawhide rawhide rawhide and steel cable
so it's just let you go i'm trained too
much i trained too hard what did you
what are you talking about homeless
people in vegas you got a joke yeah you
ever seen homeless people in vegas yeah
i didn't know beef jerky could talk
i was [ __ ] dying little sketching
can't do that joke this weekend though
oh [ __ ] no
dude i love you bro dj stevioki he said
that he sold more off his nft drop than
he's made in like ten dude that's an
issue
what a decade so you know how much he
made the dj famously sold his hairy nft
for 888 000. no no no no no million
almost a billion dollars that that's the
biggest nft drop ever
no that's 800 8 000. 88 cents no that's
not a comma
yeah that is
888 000. okay yeah you're right it
depends on how many nfts he had in that
draw yeah he didn't sell eight hours
good catch though
big bucks for that yeah wait so i
thought people made like
way more but maybe he sold multiple ones
i'm sure okay but 808 000. but that's
what he's sold he can't record in the
pandemic right because he does raise and
[ __ ] and he does around europe and
they're locked down he can't do him here
so maybe that's why he made more and
that thing straight that's the effort i
don't subscribe to this
but also i would also do one if i made
that much money
[ __ ] dude you just created all these but
in a decade he didn't make more than
eight hundred eighty eight thousand
dollars wait hey
no he was
yeah what hold on okay so okay so what
if he's talking about
music he sold he didn't say live
performances he's just saying in music
which could be the music he sold yeah
this is exactly what he says right here
you know his dad uh created uh
benihana's hell yeah oh is that true
yeah his dad's the originator benny
johannes and he has a betting hand in
his backyard wow pretty lit
he's got a bed in his house pieces
wait around until he shows up he
probably calls danny hanna's was created
by darpa
and cia
now he's talking [ __ ] there's something
that's a [ __ ] ton of money though but
bro yeah so i said peace is not peace so
definitely multiple ones oh got it all
right
each one was going for that much yes
yeah uh
i don't watch this show but i i guess
i've been on this show i've been up to
date okay so so one of his
ex-girlfriends really has the best joke
he did on king's thing he said hugh
hefner was like
but before the me too cameron goes
they're doing what me too
perfect
[Laughter]
this documentary is tough because they
go and like i will give it to i think
it's on uh
it's on amy i will give him credit
because they have some girls who had a
horrible horrible experience at the
playboy mansion they have a lot who had
a great experience they have his best
friend who's like hugh was nothing but
loving man and then what's interesting
is
so many of the girls like so many of
them came out they're on the dock with
so many have came out in the news been
like this slander they're doing cue we
did not experience any of that it was a
great time you know we knew what we were
signed up for but they have the few that
had a you know not such a great time
by the way uh
you know the playboy mansion cia
honeypot
of
course right
or they used to film i know but also and
then somebody recently bought it and
they got rid of all the tunnels
they had tunnels
tunnels it's what jeffrey epstein did
where they got they compromised yeah
which is true they're
powerful men like banging really hot
yeah or doing weird [ __ ] hollywood
doesn't need to see like you know you
like to get pegged into buttocks but
hollywood doesn't need anybody to help
them be weird right you know yeah but if
you're if you're a rich man a voice
hosting a talk show on the internet
on the uh back in the day if you're
hosting a talk show you don't want a
video of you getting fisted by filipino
chicks right yeah yeah the the the press
back then would never have heard it but
yeah no the prep was interesting because
he did have he was super powerful with
the press and had a lot of lapd on his
side because it does get dicey when they
start introducing drugs to the playboy
mansion like a girl passed away they had
his main assistant get busted for
cocaine and they were gonna put her away
for a long time she was gonna have to
testify against hugh hefner and she
committed suicide oh but then a lot of
the girls think she was killed like it's
all dicey yeah dude
but he had a whole team like pizzagate
any bad press he would make sure it
never got out yeah you control a lot of
the narrative
operation mockingbird look it up but so
in this article his ex-girlfriend who's
also said that she was like a drug meal
for him as well yeah she barely had a
bunch of drug meals
she was saying that she walked into the
room one day and their dog their that
they shared together he was doing stuff
to it and she's accusing him of beastie
yeah and he said like oh dogs need love
to or dog needs the uh sexy or something
like that yeah he likes to get weird
yeah so yeah it's there's no proof but
just that's her she starts saying all
you gotta say is like she wants to see
snitches snitches apparently that's the
dog too oh she she's the main oh she's
the main like yeah kind of hater on hugh
and when she was young my god she was
brave yeah she showed her it's kind of
crazy i mean yeah she looks like a star
character she looks like skeletor yes
you know she looks like they're
literally star trek hey come on guys no
she looks like she flies no nobody
normally
but now she's like snitching on a dead
guy like that's my biggest problem is
like he's not here to yeah i hate that
too yeah the worst is that holly madison
because all the girls like hold up like
his best friend's like hold on hold up
hugh could pick whatever girl he wanted
she was the only girl who sought out
hugh
went to him made sure she was his
girlfriend and now she's going bad on
him yeah he was he's like it doesn't
make sense to me yeah because
you did or like all right if you feel
that bad give back all the rent all the
money gave you for your clothes all the
food money the tv show he's like
send all that back yeah yeah he gave you
a career and now you want to [ __ ] on the
game yeah right i mean there there was a
truth some sketchy [ __ ] went down in
that mansion well she's sketchy 60 years
yeah super oh wait so but but she
married a 90 year old yeah because why
because she loves 90 year olds yeah she
got out she said she has something to do
she said she had stockholm syndrome she
goes
because they they're interviewing now
and they go well isn't that weird you're
dating old guys she's like well once i
was in there it was like a
responsibility well that's why the other
girls are like we don't subscribe to
that like she knew exactly what she was
doing
so it's so weird it's not it's just like
well just just like i mean the idea
about women empowerment but i guess that
an adult woman can't take responsibility
but
it's also that it's called p hacking
right we learned about that from your
friend where like they isolate things
and make it seem like it's a pattern
without showing you all the information
you know there's a famous comic i'm not
gonna say his name that passed away
not the one everybody's saying but
earlier earlier and then afterwards this
this woman's like he was he was uh
sexually harassing me i'm like well you
know i'm gonna wait for him
you know to give his side and you're
like dude like what do you do the guy's
not around now you're saying something
so nobody can hear the other side of it
yeah everyone's like you're so brave
you're like there's nothing brave about
it i never understand that it's like
because
there's something to be gained and also
but i want to feel for the people if
something did happen you know what i
mean but i don't want to be insensitive
but it's like
like i don't know it's just hard to like
battle that when it's like oh this this
person's dead like yeah how can they
like
defend themselves you can look at
somebody who's very strategic about
where they
what they got from it this holly madison
is a household name
because she made the decision 100
percent
and i don't want to hear that you were
unstoppable this retroactive [ __ ] is
annoying yeah it's awesome he didn't
have some different time back then in
the 60s 70s 80s you know but take
responsibility isn't it you had a tv
show yeah that was annoying you think
it's like you going doing fun stuff oh
oh the oppression nobody
nobody was yeah nobody was under the
impression that this was
how did you live with yourself wow
or who was it anna nicole smith who was
married to that 95 year old oh she's an
american success story yeah yeah she was
stripping she was just going to be a
stripper yeah and this old dude was like
i love you and she's like thank you that
[ __ ] was straight up in a
wheelchair dog
i'm leaving
[Laughter]
what else you got jen all right so we
our documentary is 10 parts long you
could do it in two yeah like after a
while mcgregor whatever
cultural market is interesting i want to
get your take on this bee what is really
interesting we talked about this before
the best ice skater ever really ever
she's 15 years old
and when i watched her skate
the um both uh
tara lipsky and the other guy didn't
didn't speak they did not say they did
something afterwards yeah so it's
because she before she went into this
she got busted for steroids they found
out that she they haven't in december
gone on with the the investigation's not
done yet so then they let her skate
which is fair well i mean
if she finishes first then she doesn't
get the medal no so they're saying until
the investigation's over and then they
find out she's convicted or
not convicted
everyone that's skating for the same
prize the the medals they can't do their
medal ceremony now because they have to
find out whether or not she's actually
really placing gold or silver or
whatever well she's growing what would
you rather would you rather um give out
like let's say she finished first right
so would you rather them go okay we're
not giving you the gold so the person
that fish seconds can't get the gold
percent finished thursday at silver
person that finished fourthly at bronze
but if this chick is cleared y'all get
we need those battles back here's what i
would rather do that no my if you got
popped you got to sit out you got popped
figured out later but for now don't
screw over every other yeah this is
[ __ ] up once every four years yeah you
gotta pop you gotta found three heart
medications in our system and he's gonna
blame her
yeah she took it from her grandfather's
medication she's also russia and russia
which is also she's also 15 and i
guarantee that she didn't have a choice
yeah of course yeah so don't make it
fair though no i agree it's not fair she
could be the most talented person but
she said russia has been caught doing
this one million times and they have a
whole program for it and
you know it was very interesting to
watch and john weird they didn't put a
[ __ ] they didn't say a [ __ ] that's
her this is her she is the best they've
ever seen they're all saying that she's
she's incredible apparently she's like
so hold on so they didn't say a word
so they did it afterwards actually on
the broadcast i can't play because it's
olympics so we got pulled last time
but i have the you know what the thing
is though that this is ice skating and i
don't give a [ __ ]
dude my favorite thing i feel like a
major sport i'd have so figure skaters
this is a huge scandal though so no i
know it's from worldwide figure skaters
and strippers love to dance to the same
song yeah i'm just a girl in this world
right and it's like no doubt so this is
blondie
is that it was on the program of camilla
the olympics
uh she had a positive test we should not
have seen this skate lepinsky said uh
the duo both expressed frustration
disappointment all right uh makes me
angry and disoriented by everything i
thought i knew
it makes me question everything these
skaters give up their lives for this
moment to get this place why when do you
see johnny swear do you think that
sexuality is a choice would you say
right when you see johnny are you like
yeah you can pick if you're gay or not
right that's a some people believe like
you would like this is who this dude is
he's so good so i'll just play it real
quick yeah he's [ __ ]
on the broadcast
he's a what he's he's also a skater or a
former skater right yeah that's rainbow
everybody listening to our coverage of
the women's short program live from take
off your map [ __ ] man i've ever had to
cover
and i want to thank you all for
supporting the skaters that should be in
this competition whose life's work is on
the line thank you
so they're all
against this yeah bring up johnny we're
all against her skating and also brian
your favorite guy
uh this guy adam rippon i don't know oh
that remember the little cutie yeah
remember that you said that
tomorrow's complete jokes not real
competitions most likely won't even have
a medal ceremony so many olympic
experiences stolen from clean athletes
who got here without the help i feel so
bad for that
all the little girls that practice all
their lives to get the medal ceremony
they can't do it because it's this
girl's investigation yeah yeah i'm bad
about for that girl too i guarantee yeah
you're right brian
teen there's no way she's like give me
all the difference she doesn't know that
she may not even know she's not a kid
she said this is she's at 15. i know
she's talking about she's dumb you were
at 15 years old dumb as [ __ ] no i'm
saying it's like it's completely it's a
government program yeah when you're a
russian athlete oh now you believe it's
governor program
oh now the government's involved weird
no i'm just saying now you're buying
back you can't dying other governments
can be yeah
yeah that was really weird i watched
that man it was dead quiet bring up
johnny ware i got a show have you not
seen this guy no i don't follow male 1
is looking to see if he has an only fan
what a character look at his outfits
dude he is so funny i'm like good for
him just uh
look at his hair oh he lived in his best
life
dude i usually play this game go back to
him and his guy look at him can you go
up one real quick over over to him and
look like adam lamb
i usually play a game top or bottom i
don't know i think it's equal
[Laughter]
this one's a coin flip it just all
depends on who has a chinese that night
i guess i don't know but it's just like
nobody knows
i'm usually good i can sense this yeah
that one's
they're both trying to upstage each
other with their outfits oh yeah oh yeah
whoever dresses best that night well
with the outfits i'd say the guy on the
right the top that's great it says they
say if i had to guess what they split so
maybe it just didn't work out because oh
yeah
they're like two magnets down the same
side just pushing away from each other
he is he is just a very feminine man
very
very gender fluid man there yeah dude
that dude was
bored a chick with a dick for sure so
this is for brennan uh
taylor sheridan the director writer
everything for yeah we all sound he's
saying there's going to be multiple new
shows now hell yeah uh 1883 is getting a
second season a sequel called another
sequel called 1932 as well okay i'm in
yeah
so he's the original creator and writer
for the yellowstone
1883 which is the prequel to that and
now they're coming out with a 1932
no but you know where what he wasn't he
was an actor for a long time yeah he
actually was he was always yeah
but he was also an actor in um
[ __ ] uh the vampires thing um
no uh interview with a vampire no lost
voice no it was a lost blood or
true blood true blood triple idea played
the cop
i don't remember that that sounds like
that's kind of it was on sons of anarchy
you see it
oh maybe that's what it was he played
the cop he played the competition i
don't think he was in true blood he
wasn't tribal though
uh you think he's walker texas ranger he
was on walker
like he would show up like in small
parts they need to bring it back but he
still writes himself in all the yeah
it's not real
hell or high water he wrote great heller
high waters
amazing
yeah he's a monster guy
all right that's it that's it
sammy boy sam sam
tripoli samuel the facts triple really
we're gonna have a job i can talk about
anything schedule their debates
diversion amusements sam and i are
debating and then we're gonna do
stand-up after that but we're gonna have
it very orderly i'm gonna i'm working
out on the whole thank you for having me
on
apparently i'm dangerous
is that what they tell you
i don't know we'll find out i never get
invited so thank you for having me
i know the psychological game being
played right now
you know how it goes dude
um what i got next wednesday sam won't
be there for whatever reason but i'm at
the hollywood improv shop and friends
february 23rd you know how that goes we
get some monsters there that's one show
only hollywood improv 8 pm then
sacramento we got 30 tickets left i
can't add shows so i'm telling you man
we're going to sell out february 24th to
26th at the punchline sacramento just
announced nashville tennessee zanies
march 10th through the 12th chicago is
march 24th 26th and they just had
phoenix april 14th the 16th come see me
by the way in um
las vegas oh [ __ ] tomorrow i'm at the
american comedy company yeah san diego
february 17th um get your tickets
tomorrow night then i got um yeah then
then las vegas on saturday with sam
diversion amusements february 19th
appleton wisconsin skyline comedy club
march 3rd to the 5th phoenix arizona
stand up live march 11 to the 13
louisville kentucky march 17 19 every
[ __ ] weekend in [ __ ] march you're
gonna be so bored in appleton look at
chappelle lazy doing great
february 25th and 26th kansas city the
comedy club of kansas city march 10th
through the 12th uh springfield missouri
blue room comedy club uh april 8th and
april 9th salt lake city wise guys
comedy club and then one nighter uh may
12th uh stand up live
level up bro thank you brother headline
thank you man love to see you're a good
dude thank you brother all right kids
love you oh the oops combat says fight
companion tees hoodies and hats drop
next tuesday you've seen me rock you
seen dalia rocket that drops next
tuesday on thick boy all right love you
guys